[Music]
Alijah you are scaring the bejesus out
of me
who does not love this game it is a
classic the rules are pretty
straightforward with one hand only you
remove a brick from a lower level and
place it on top as you go of course that
tower gets taller and taller and less
stable and eventually usually crashes
down Elijah are you ready
no but there is one mythically
impossible move in Jenga and that is in
a late stage game if the whole tower
rests on a single brick the myth is that
it's impossible to remove that ring
without the whole tower crashing down I
think that's a testable proposition
I was thinking a pneumatic actuator
which I actually got from my robotics
experience I was like oh you want you
want to push something out that's fast
and that's strong yeah pneumatic
actuator perfect with an air-powered
piston mounted to the base of a swing
arm the speed is maximized and the block
is knocked out in theory I'm excited
with the air tank connected valerie's
ready for a low pressure
proof-of-concept three okay that's a
precarious late-stage Jenga game will
her air powered piston pull off the
impossible
the waiting is over I'm gonna charge the
tank with the air pressure set to its
maximum rating okay we're at 120 psi it
is your experiment counted it
and Valerie's nerves equally
highly-charged
my god I just got butterflies in my
stomach no lie I'm like oh my god okay
okay this is the myths last chance
this is pneumatic actuator test three
two one that was really cool that was
amazing
it was so much cooler they thought it
would be after seeing the previous test
three out of three failures but they're
not calling it yet the gene thinks
there's an issue with the super-sized
blocks our thought process was that if
we made this huge Jenga tower then we
could have bigger blocks which would
mean that there's a larger thing to grab
so it'd be easier to yank it out from
the bottom well we didn't account for is
the amount of weight that was the
pressing down on it would get a lot more
than actual gameplay
in scaling up our Jenga bricks as cool
as that was we messed up the physics see
when you scale something up I linked
with in height you also have to
commensurately scale its weight and thus
to finally test their rigs and call this
myth now going back to the normal sized
Jenga and with their rigs remodel I'd
for standard sized blocks they're ready
where's that thing that I had that I was
almost ready to go again
wait did you catch me cursing I can't
believe I care so good third time's a
charm okay all right we're in
everybody focus I'm going to have gray
hairs at the end of this I think we all
are I already had a gray hair after
first grade oh that is awesome question
is will it work
are you ready Elijah final small-scale
bunch of test Jenga tower in three two
one that was incredible
one dude that was a lot more successful
I think we're on the right track
going for the small-scale tango punch in
buddy yeah
Allie's next the bike is attached to the
fishing line and calibers the terror
constructed a nickname bestowed you
better not be writing cake me Oh God no
I'm giving you a nickname here I'm
calling you crash okay I hope I don't
though it's a nickname not a prophecy
and launch procedure initiated Jenga
bike test final in three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
I see no tower totally destroyed a
perfect figure
that was really really fun actually I
like to think of myself as very
competitive but I try not to let it get
in the way of just important things like
this
Valerie's up last
will this Jenga journey end in a block
party or will they crashing learn this
is pneumatic actuator test a hundred and
twenty psi final test Oh three
- one that was amazing one
Oh amazing that was awesome amazing one
you you couldn't even see that are just
like crews gone that's great it's a
samurai Jenga that's what you've
invented a brand-new dick all right
amazing well done thank you I did the
impossible Jenga bug oh my god 20 psi
and this thing is standing my pneumatic
actuator pushed out the impossible Jenga
block which was just amazing yep with an
impact velocity of 75 miles per hour
there's little time for friction and the
tower stays standing at this point you
might be wondering I can hear you
thinking I wonder how much those
mechanical solutions the kids came up
with themselves and I'm here to tell you
they did and it totally worked the
impossible Jenga move is in fact
possible one